สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  6  6 ปีค.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  23 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 7 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  23 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
คะพรุ่งนี้วัน
จันท์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 อืปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
คะตอนนี้เวลา 14 น 14 นกี่
นาที 8 นาทีค่ะค่ะ 14
น 8 นเนาะเก็เป็นตอนกลาง
วันแต่ว่าตอนนี้ที่กรุงเทพฯก็คือดวง
อาทิตย์เนี่ยไม่มีเลยนะคะมีแต่ก้อนเมฆ
ก้อนเมฆก้อน
เมฆผู้หญิงฝนน่าจะตกนะคะร้อนมยโอหก็ร้อน
นะปูฟ้า 32 องศ
เซลเซียร้อนอืร้อนนะที่ออสเตรเลียเป็นยัง
ไงคะหนาวมั้ยที่ออสเตรเลียเหรอคะ
เอิ่มครูฟ้าเช็คก่อนได้
ค่ะเช็คที่โทรศัพท์เหรอคะเช็คที่โทรศัพท์
นะคะโ
โทรศัพท์
นี่
โอ้โห
หหแดดแรงอยู่นะคะครูฟ้า
ใช่แดดแรงนะคะแต่ว่าก็เย็นๆนะอากาศไม่
ร้อนเย็นนะคะครูฟ้าอยากเปิดฮีตเตอร์มาก
เลยแล้วก็อ่าได้ค่ะครูฟ้าเปิดฮีตเตอร์ได้
เลยเพราะว่าถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยหนาวเนี่ยอาจจะ
คิดไม่ได้
เอ้าอะไรคะครูหญิงฟอันนี้ครูฟ้าเอ้าวัน
นี้ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีเกมมีเกมมาเล่นกับครู
ฟ้าไงครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องฟังครูหญิงดูรูปครู
หญิงจะมีรูปให้ดูด้วยใช้ตาเนี่ยนะคะ
ดูใช้
หูฟังแล้วก็
ใช้
สมองเกาหัวไม่ได้นะคะคิดค่ะคิดคิดถ้าไม่
มีสมองโอเค
มยก็โอเคนะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าไม่มีอยู่แล้วไง
อ้าวครูหญิงพูดไม่ดีนะคะไม่ได้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีครูฟ้าเป็นคนที่คิดเก่งนะดูเป็นคน
มีไอเดียเอนี่พูดจริงๆ
นะูฟ้าบอกผู้หญิงโอเคหรือ
เปล่าต้องใช้สมองนะคะนักเรียน
สมองสมองใช่อยู่ข้างในเนี่ยูฟ้าต้องคิดนะ
คะคิดอีกแล้วครูหญิงเคยเล่นเกมแบบนี้กับ
ครูฟ้าไปแล้วแล้วไงที่ว่ามีหลุมอุ้ยต้อง
เปลี่ยนนะคะมีหลุมใช่มั้ยแล้วมีผู้ชาย
อยู่ใน
หลุมแล้วจะปล่อยคนไม่ดีเนี่ยจะปล่อยน้ำลง
มาผู้ชายเนี่ยจะขึ้นขึ้นจากหลุมยังไงวัน
นี้ก็คล้ายๆกันครูฟ้าต้องคิดแล้วว่าเอ๊ะ
เค้าจะทำยังไง
อืต้องคิดคิดคิดใแตู่หญิงมีมีช้อยส์มี
ช้อยส์ให้เลือกอยู่แล้วไม่ใช่มีช้อยส์สิ
มีทางเลือกให้ละกันนะคะอ่ะไปฟังเลยดีกว่า
นะคะคูณฟ้าดูรูปนี้แล้วคิดว่าอะไร
คะรูปนี้นะ
คะครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนไม่ดีค่ะหทำไมทำไมครูฟ้า
เห็นรูปนี้แล้วคิดว่าคนไม่ดีล่ะคะเพราะ
ว่านี่นะคะนักเรียนอันนี้คือคนใช่มยค่ะคน
นะคะอยู่ใน
คุก
อืทำไมถึง
อ่าคุกนะ
คะดูเสื้อใส่สิใช่มั้ยเสื้อเป็น
ลายสีดำสีขาวใช่มั้ยคะอ่าเพราะว่าถ้าคนดี
ๆเชเช็คดริปเปอร์คนที่ดีๆแบบครูหญิงครู
ฟ้าแล้วก็นักเรียนเนี่ยเราก็ต้องอยู่ที่
บ้านใช่มยอยู่บ้านออพาร์ทเมนต์
คอนโดมิเนียมถ้าในคุกนี้ก็ต้องเป็นคนไม่
ดีใช่ค่ะผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะจริงๆเค้าเป็นผู้
ชายนะคะผู้หญิงวาดผมให้แล้วเคก็มีตามีปาก
นะคะนี่ผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยเค้าติดคุกเหมือน
ในรูปนี้นะ
คะแต่
ว่าอะไรคะนี่คุกนี่คุกนะคะครูฟ้าข้างใน
นี่ไงนักเรียนหนีเห็น
มยอันนี้คือคุกเหรอคะผู้หญิงใช่มันมันดี
ไปนิดหน่อยมมีเตียงเออมีตีก็โอเคนะมี
หมอนมีอ่างลข้างหน้ามีกระจกให้แต่ดูสิตรง
นี้ใช่มก็มีประตูล็อคเอาไว้เนี่ยก็ติดคุก
ดีแต่ต้องอยู่ในนี้ไงไปเเว่นอวไปช้อปปิ้ง
ไม่ได้
อือยู่ที่นี่บางคนเนี่ย 10 ปีบางคน 20 ปี
ใช่มยก็แล้วแต่คนอืทำไมหรือว่าบางคน 120
ปีอะไรคะครูฟ้าอะไรคะเนี่ยห้าหลุมเหรอมี
หลุมค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเห็นคุกในรูปเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าเห็นคนอยู่ในคุกมั้ยล่ะไม่มีคน
เอ้อ
เอิ่มไม่มีคนค่ะใช่เพราะว่าในคุกเนี่ย
ต้องมีมีคนจริงๆในคุกเนี่ยมีผู้ชายใช่
มั้ยที่ครูหญิงบอกคนเนี้ยเป็นผู้ชายเขา
ชื่อว่าแมทนะคะเห็นมั้ยมีชื่อด้วยจริงๆ
เนี่ยมีผู้ชายอยู่ในคุกเนี่ย 1
คนนี่มิสเตอแมทใช่มั้ยคะแต่เขาคไม่อยู่
เค้าจะออกทางประตูก็ไม่ได้เห็นไว่าประตู
เนี่ยปิดอยู่หรือ
ว่าหน้าต่าง
ก็ไม่ได้ใช่มยเพราะว่าูคนเนี่ยรอดผ่าน
ช่องแค่นี้ไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียนช่องนี้
เนี่ยมันเล็กมากๆคนเนี่ยออกไม่
ได้แล้ว
คนอยู่ที่ไหนคะครูหญิง
เ้านี่ไงครูฟ้าเห็นหลุมตรงนี้ใช่มยก็
อืคนนี้เนี่ยแหละค่ะแมทเนี่ยนะคะเขาคิด
คิดไม่อยากอยู่ในคุกใช่มยแต่ออกที่ประตู
เนี่ยไม่ได้หน้าต่างไม่ได้ก็คิดอทำยังไง
ดีน้าจนสุดท้ายเนี่ยเขาค
ก็คิดออกว่าโอเคเขาก็ขุดผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้
นะคะว่าเค้าทุบยังไงนะคะเเอาอะไรน่ะทุบุบ
ุบจนเป็นหลุมเห็นมั้ยเนี่ยเป็นหลุมตรงนี้
เลยอแล้ว
อแล้วแมทเนี่ยก็ลงไปในหลุมแล้วก็ขุดขุด
ขุดเป็นทางแบบนี้ค่ะครู
ฟ้านี่
โอนี่ค่ะมิสเตแทนะคะมสมเห็นมั้ยจ้านี่
เห็นมยเนี่ยสีฟ้าๆเนี่ยเหมือนกันใช่มั้ย
คะเนี่ยเขาคก็ขุด
ๆดแล้วก็มีทางเนี่ยหนีมาอุ๊ยอืกระดูกอะไร
คะเนี่ยนี่กระดูกคนหรือเปล่าเนี่ยเหมือน
หน้า
คนใช่ค่ะแมทเนี่ยเขาก็ขุดแล้วก็หนีใช่ม
คลานเนี่ยในรูปเนี่ยนะคะแมทเากำลังคลานมา
ทางช่องที่เขาขไว้แล้วมาเรื่อยๆพอมาถึง
ตรงนี้ปุ๊บก็มาเจอกับทางเนี่ยทางที่ 1
ทางที่ 2 ทางที่ 3 เป็นทางแยกใช่ไหมมี 3
ทาง
อืก็ต้องเลือไปที่ไหนอ่ะไปทางไหนใช่ค่ะก็
ต้องเลือกว่า
เอ๊ะจะไปทางที่ 1  1 หรือว่าจะไปทางที่ 2
หรือว่าจะไปทางที่ 3 ใช่มยคะมี 3 ทาง
เลือกให้ให้เลือกแต่ยังไม่เสร็จนะยังไม่
เสร็จนะไม่ใช่แค่ไม่ใช่ให้ครูฟ้าคิด
ว่าผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยจะเลือกทางที่ 1 ทาง
ที่ 2 หรือว่าทางที่ 3 เพราะว่าครูหญิง
คิดว่าครูฟ้าถึงแม้ครูฟ้าจะไอคิว
180 ครูฟ้าก็คิดไม่ออกค่ะเพราะว่ามันไม่
เข้าใจใช่ค่ะอืครูหญิงก็เลยมีให้เลือด
นี่มี 3 ทางใช่มยคะทางที่ 1 เนี่ยถ้าแมท
จะไปทางที่ 1 เนี่ยนะคะแมทก็จะเจอกับ
ระเบิดนี่ระเบิดเวลาด้วยนะฟ้าเห็นมั้ย
เนี่ยระเบิดเวลาระเบิดเวลาค่ะมีนาฬิกา
เห็นมยมีนาฬิกาอยู่นะคะถ้ามีคนอยู่ที่ไหน
ไม่รู้แล้วก็กดปิ๊มันก็จะระเบิดตู้มนะคะ
มีระเบิดเวลาเพราะว่าระเบิดเวลาเนี่ยมัน
จะมีเวลาใช่มั้ยคะอาจจะอีก
60 วินาทีเนาะ 60
วินาทีติ๊กๆๆมันก็จะลดลงมาใช่มั้ย 60
58 จะค่อยๆค่อยๆค่อยๆแล้วก็ระเบิดเนาะ
อันนี้คือทางที่ 1 เนี่ยนะคะระเบิดเวลา
ทางที่ 2 ทางที่ 2 ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรคะทาง
ที่ 2 งูค่ะงูงูเยอะมั้ยงูกี่งู 1  2  3
4  5  6  6 ตัว
ค่ะครูฟ้าชอบงูตัวไหน
คะครูฟ้าชอบตัวที่ 1 แล้วะ
กันครูฟ้าบอกผู้หญิงถามอะไรเห็นมั้ยงูแต่
นี้เป็นงูธรรมดามั้ยครูฟ้าดูจากหน้าใช่ไ
มันคืองู
อะไรงูเห่าค่ะครูฟ้าเป็นงูกว้างๆกว้างๆ
เนาะเอ่าอืองูพิษน่ะนะคะนักเรียนเรียนอ่ะ
พูดพูดแบบกว้างๆแบบที่ภูฟ้าบอกก็ได้ว่างู
พิษงูพิษก็คืองูตัวนี้เนี่ยถ้ามันกัด
เราเราตายนะคะอันนี้คืองูพิษนะคะนักเรียน
ถ้า
มันตายอันนี้คือทางที่ 2 เนี่ยก็จะเจอกับ
งูพิษนะคะทางที่ 3 ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไร
คะ
ไฟค่ะ
เออไฟใช่มยมีไฟอยู่เนี่ยแหละมี 3 ทางทาง
ที่ 1 ระเบิดเวลาทางที่ 2 งูพิษทางที่ 3
ไฟครูฟ้าคิดว่าผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยนะคะแมท
เนี่ยจะเลือกทางไหนดีที่เค้าเนี่ยจะหนี
ออกไปได้ไม่ไม่
ตายูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะคิด
ไว้เลือก 1 นะครูฟ้าเลือก 1 นะก็เลือก 1
ค่ะ
อืเพครูฟ้าเลือกาที่เลือก 1 ก็ครูหญิงบอก
ให้เลือก 1 ไม่ใช่ครูหญิงไม่ได้บอกว่าให้
เลือก 1 อันนี้หมายถึงว่ามันมี 1  2  3  3
ทางเนี่ยครูฟ้าเลือก 1 ก็คือเลือก 1 ทาง
ถ้าครูฟ้าเลือกทางที่ 2 ก็ทางที่ 2 เท่า
นั้นจะเลือกทางที่ 2 ทางที่ 3 แบบนี้ไม่
ได้อันนี้ให้เลือก 1 ทางเลือก 1 ของครู
หญิงเนี่ยอ่ะครูฟ้าเลือกทางไหนคะครูฟ้า
เลือกถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นผู้ชายคนนี้ถ้าครูฟ้า
เลือกถูกครูฟ้าก็จะไม่เป็นแบบนี้แต่ถ้า
ครูฟ้าเลือกผิดก็ Before  After
ตายครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี 2  Choice นะคะคือ 1
กับ
2 ทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูฟ้าถึงคิดว่าเอ๊น่าจะ
เป็น 1 หรือ 2 อ่ะทำไมไม่ไม่มี 3 อยู่ใน
นี้เลยเหรอคือ 3 เนี่ยไม่เอาเอ้าถ้าเรา
โดนไฟเราก็ตายสิ
อ่าโอเคเมมันมีไฟนะคะเรา
ตายตายเลยแต่ว่าช้อยส์ที่ 1 เนี่ยอืถ้า
เรารีบไปเร็วๆมันก็อาจจะโอเคมั้ยเออใช่
เพราะอนี้เป็นระเบิดเวลานะมันมีเวลาปกติ
ระเบิดเวลามันจะประมาณเท่าไหร่ 15 นาที
มยเวลาดูตามแบบฮอลีวูดอะไรอย่างเงี้ยผู้
หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะว่าระเบิดเวลา
เนี่ยเขาจะตั้งไว้อืนาทีแล้วก็ตู้มระเบิด
เอ้อแล้วก็ทางที่ 2 ทำไมคิดถึงทำไมคิดทาง
ที่ 2 คะทางที่ 2 เนี่ยมีงูนะคะงูมันเป็น
งูพิษนะแต่เราก็ขัดแล้วเราตายนะเราก็ฆ่า
งูก่อนค่อยไปไงเอาอะไรฆ่า
งูอ๋อเอาระเบิดมาฆ่างู่างใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าถ้า
เอาระเบิดมาเออเอาระเบิดตีงูแล้วก็ระเบิด
ตู้มงูก็ตายเราก็ตายนะ
เอาเอาระเบิดมาตีงูแล้วเราก็รีบไปหลบไงคะ
อ๋อหนีขึ้นไปข้างบนก่อนมอืเอาระเบิดมา
แล้วก็หนีหนีขึ้นมาข้างบนก่อนอ่ะครูฟ้าตก
ลงครูฟ้าจะเลือกทางไหนเลือก 1 ค่ะค่ะ 1
ทางเลือก 1 ค่ะเลือก 1 ใช่ค่ะ 1 อ่าเลือก
ทางที่ 1
ใช่ทำไมทำไมครูฟ้าถึงเลือกทางที่ 1 ล่ะ
ระเบิด
นะเราเอาระเบิดออกมาก็ได้
มยคิดได้ไงมีระเบิดกี่อันเนี่ยมีระเบิด 1
1  2  3  4  5  6 ใช่มยมีระเบิด 6 อัน
เอาระเบิดออกมาไว้ที่ไหนก็ได้อย่างเงี้ย
เหรอใช่แล้วก็ไปแล้วก็ไป
อืใช่คือสำหรับครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะตอนที่ครู
หญิงดูครูหญิงก็คิดคือทางที่ 2 ครูหญิง
ไม่เลือกแน่นอน 100% นะคะทำไมอ่ะไม่เอา
ครูฟังงูพิษเนี่ยงูมันกัดแล้วแล้วเราตาย
เลยนะคะเราก็ฆ่างูก่อนค่ะโเอาอะไรฆ่างู
ล่ะคะ
เอ้าคนไม่ดีนะคะนักเรียนคนไม่ดีเนี่ยเค้า
ก็ต้อง
มีมีมีดนะมีมีดเออเอาจจะมีมีดก็ได้นะเอ
หรือว่าเค้าอาจจะมีกระจุก
มืข้างบนห้องอ่ะ
อ่านี่ไงบนมีกระกนี่ใช่ปก็อาจจะทุบกระจก
ไงแล้วก็เอาเอ้อแต่เค้าขุดอ่ะเค้าขุดหนี
ลงมาได้อะไเมีอะไรสำหรับฆ่างูไว
อืใช่ค่ะซึ่งเวลาที่เราฟังแล้วเราเลือก
เนี่ยเราก็จะคิดเอ่อไม่เอาทางที่ 3 แน่
นอนใช่มั้ยคะ 1 บางคนอาจจะคิด 1 ซึ่งครู
หญิงก็คิด 1 นะแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่เอา 2
แน่นอนนะคะอ่ะมาฟังนะคะว่าจริงๆแล้วผู้
ชายคนนี้เนี่ยทำยังไงและต้องเลือกทางไหน
ดีครูฟ้าบอกว่าทางที่ 1 ใช่
มั้ยไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าถึงเราเรา
ต้องหนีเร็วแค่ไหนมันถึงจะระระเบิดมันจะ
ไม่ระเบิดใช่มั้ยคะครู
ฟ้าเราก็เลือกทางที่ 3 สิคะทำไมล่ะครู
หญิงเงอโหคุณหญิงเงอะด้วยนะคะอันนี้มันมี
ไฟใช่มแต่ว่าตรงเนี้ยมันเป็นดินเห็นมย
ทั้งหมดเนี่ยมันคือดินอเราเนี่ยนะคะก็เอา
ดินเนี่ยเอาดินเนี่ยดับไฟอืเราก็เอาดิน
ใส่เนี่ยไฟก็ดับแล้วแล้วเราก็ไป
ได้ผู้หญิง IQ ดีป่ะ
ครูหญิงครูหญิงดูมาจาก YouTube ไม่ใช่ครู
หญิงคิดเองครูฟ้ารู้นะคะเหรู้อะไรคะครู
ฟ้ารู้ว่าเอาดินดับไฟพี่กินมันดับไฟได้
จริงๆนะครูฟ้าเคยกินบาร์บีคิวมั้ยล่ะเวลา
บาร์บีคิวมันมีไฟแรงๆเราก็เอาดินวางปุ๊บ
อืมันมีน้ำ
ไงใช่ตัวดินเองอ่ะมันก็ดับได้เห็นมั้ยเอา
ดินดับไฟซะเราก็หนีไปทางนี้ได้หนีไปทาง
นี้ยังไงก็เจองูก็ตายหรือว่าทางที่ 1
เป็นระเบิดก็อย่างที่ครูหิงบอกว่าเราต้อง
หนีเร็วแค่ไหนไม่ระเบิดนะคะนักเรียนเนี่ย
เล่นเกมนี้แล้วตอบถูกมยหรือว่าผิดนะคะก็
คอมเมนต์คุยกันได้เนาะว่าค่ะนักเรียนคิด
เนี่ยมันถูกหรือว่าผิดนะคะแต่ว่าวีีดีโอ
นี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะใช่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ